[Musik]
liebe -fans donnerstag der fünfte neunte
der dritte tag der einkünfte zu erbauer
und alles läuft plangemäß bin sehr
begeistert dass wir also die statische
schau bereits zu zwei drittel voll haben
wir haben gestern bereits die frecce
tricolori empfangen dürfen die haben
dass die erste training schon gemacht
also wir sind auf gott
wir sind bereit für die tolle flugshow
heute tolles wetter für die letzten
ankünfte und trainings also die erbauer
2019 läuft wir erwarten heute noch
weitere einkünfte die schweizer patrick
swiss wird kommen auch ein training
durchführen wir freuen uns ganz
besonders ein highlight der f-35 aus
italien kommt zuerst einmal in
österreich zu sehen
weitere tolle displays werden wir
nachmittag trainieren und ich kann sagen
die erbauer 19 füllt sich langsam